citizens of the reject Nation it's me Tera Eric
a long time my dear close personal friend we've
been watching movies for a minute now huh say
your name Andrew Flash Gordon oo that was good
I like that we're going to watch The Exorcist I'm
actually uh scared cuz he built it up telling a
story about his dad so my dad saw this in 1973 the
year it came out and he told me that the theater
was packed full of people and when he went to
see it by the end credits there were only two
people remaining plus himself so it'd be three
and so I'm like great yeah that's terrifying I'm
terrified so you know just leave a like leave a
comment tell us um how great we look when we get
spooked out and also do not forget to ring the
bell ring the bell to subscribe also if you are
not a super sexy reject you should get on board
and you get on board by going to patreon.com and
signing up the Royal Rejects and pledging some
MOA to support us all also don't forget that
Greg and John cover several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included that was like my rap it could
have been a lot better but I thought that was
great it was pretty good right you guys are like
four stars four out of five I totally absolutely
agree uh here's my scream in preparation are you
ready I'm ready okay I'm ready to lose some Do It
Go the music oh my
goodness it's like very religious
type of music I am already
scared
scared of what you're going to find whoa all
right don't reach in there please I wonder if
he's like where are the skulls at what are we
doing with these coins and plates here oh God is
that a baby skull what is it it looks like a heart
is he naturally like that or because of all the
stuff he's been touching I feel like
he found that baby skull and freaked
out yeah something's wrong with him I mean that
artifact that he found must have meant something
big and we don't know what it is yet oh gosh it's
the sound man jump scare number one out of the
way
who started as friends we are now
Brothers this actor is doing a good
job of just making me feel easy watching him
though yeah like that something is really
wrong especially when they said evil against
evil like when he was holding that artifact
it's sort of like the evil is brewing
within him and he must go take care of
it God this is so Eerie
yeah it's the sound is like
yeah oh what the fudge oh my
goodness
what oh my God the sound of this is
killing me oh my God that's so spooky
yeah is that a script yeah looks like
it can tell this is going to be a pattern
of we're going to be scared by noises yeah
right what the heck is that it's is it a dog
or what's that noise there's
probably like a crow in the
Attic NOP just a window open I mean again it's
super hurly in the film but all the noises that
they're making are just creepy the dog thing
freaked me out yeah even when they were hitting
the iron with the coal yeah everything oh Carl
we've got rats in the atct you better get some
traps oh oh okay on set
cool I like how it's it says Warner
Brothers on there and Warner Brothers
made the film it's very meta yeah C
you you can't accomplish anything by
shutting okay cut that's actors's favorite words
cut that's a w but then I get post gig depression
and I just want to go back to set I think walk
home tonight M okay you take that drop by my
house I've definitely heard this music in the
past well it's also it's also a Halloween I
was going to say yeah that and also I've
been to haunted houses and Ma exist I've
heard this music there okay it's iconic I
know what everyone's thinking for someone
who does get scared so easily why do I like
haunted houses talk to them all I don't know
anyone can't we get a horse well now we're in
Washington back oh they have such
a cute relationship mom I could
take you somewhere where you'd be
safe you wouldn't be alone this is
my house and I'm not going no place
stubborn but I get where she's coming
from a nice son that's such an old school
$10 bill he's a good boy yeah he's a nice
son he's just trying to look out for her too
when he was making that suggestion oh yeah for
sure sure hey where' this come from you been
playing with it yep you know how I have never
played with a Ouija board oh yeah well let's
both Captain howdy said no Captain howdy do
you think my mom's pretty Captain howdy that
isn't very nice well maybe he's sleeping hey
you know we never finished seeing all the sits
in Washington and tomorrow night I'll take you
to a movie okay oh I love you a really doing
a good job making you feel the history between
these two yeah you can bring Mr Dennings if you
like cuz BR and I are just friends okay really
okay the SE the sound change yeah
Andrew already needs a new pair of
underwear it's my mother Tom I need
reassignment Tom I went out of this
job it's wrong it's it's no good I need
out I'm unfit I think I've lost my faith
tomoh that's not a good thing as a priest
NP Jesus Christ can you believe this he
doesn't even call his daughter on her
birthday for Christ's sake maybe the
circuit is busy oh circuit's my ass oh
I thought the dad had perished I thought
that too cuz she was wearing her wedding
ring too and the way they were talking I
thought he was gone what are you doing
here my bed was shaking I can't get to
sleep okay yeah I don't think it's
rats what's that sound I don't like
it rats usually just sound like crawling sounds
that's yeah it sounds like a monster about to
Roar my God God girl get a flashlight
what are we doing here you have a
lot of people that work for you
just get one of them to do get up
there okay the tension
suspense what the uh Jesus Christ Carl don't do
that no rats no rats thanks a lot that's terrific
I still would want to know what the heck that
sound was yeah I'd be like does anybody else hear
this whoa that's up
yeah like all of this is super intense oh what
girl what why no can you feel this I don't feel
anything okay what happened to herang they took
her blood now she's a different person what's
going on here this tells your temperature and the
red light goes on that's your temperature that's
old pent up with anger oh my God what is
going on I mean she mentioned her bed was
shaking when she was in it oh right and then
she saw that the image in her head yeah Rin
I think that's the answer have you ever known
your daughter to swear no never well she let
loose quite a string while I was examining her
visit me well I find that hard to believe what'd
she say I wanted to hear it she advised
me to keep my fingers away from her God
you don't think a psychiatrist uh I do the edem
affected her brain you understand him she don't
let no doctor come near her she was all the time
screaming even talking to the radio you should
have called me the minute it happened oh boy Mama
it's Demi mama oh no poor poor thing why you did
this why could you put us someplace else like what
Private Hospital who got the money for that de
you that was a really quick cut scene boxing I
get what they were trying to established like
hey I'm letting out some like that was like a
5c yeah yeah totally Mike what goes on there I
mean who's the priest I keep seeing there Damen
Carris he's our our psychiatric counselor he
had a pretty rough knock last night poor guy his
mother passed away oh no my God that's so sad you
see oh she is not cuz she's
demented he plays drunk pretty well I like that
guy I'm a method actor I would actually
get drunk so I could just naturally do
it oh girl she's like I can't
sleep shut up you're going to die
there what is happening holy to Molly
honey the bathroom's over there honey
what's the matter I'm sorry she's
been sick she didn't know what she
was say rlin just kicked in is
it coming out Willie I think so
good oh God poor
thing oh our bed is shaking okay at least
the mom got to see it and knows she's not
like she's not full of crap now okay
from this point forward she's sleeping
in my or we're leaving the house first of
all right or or she'll just have to sleep
with mom cuz Mom bed has not shaken yet
they're going to have to see that priest
ASAP oh no that was the same image she saw
right with the possession yeah I don't want it
bastard it's rare but it does cause
bizarre hallucinations shaking of the
bed that's doubtless due to muscular spasms
oh no no no that was no spasm there do the
whole bed was thumping and Rising off the
floor and shaking the whole thing with me
on it it's her brain no no doctor it's just
like at this point what are you supposed to
I don't know you're going to feel something
a little bit cold and wet what are they doing
I'm assuming a cat scin but I don't know are
they doing the temperor lobe thing oh boy looks
painful oh boy that looks even more painful
you're going to feel some pressure here now
don't I mean knock her out
what are we doing here oh my
God no thank
you yeah I don't want to see that
either okay I just have to pretend
it's fine it's a movie it's a movie I
like blood when it's like you have to
kill someone and it's revenge or
it's like a zombie but this ah H
up oh my God
oh let me guess her frontal
Lo is fine there's nothing
there no vascular displacement at all
Chris no's on the phone she says it's
urg something oh my God please
mother oh make it stop he's holy
junk all
right the is
mine me
whoa stay away from me oh my
God
okay this is
intense Dr Tanny says the x-rays are negative
in other words normal ah there's nothing more
these guys can do I think it's time
we started looking for a psychiatrist
I think she suggested that a while back to
you sir uh pretty sure she's been saying we
should get one and you guys have been like
let's do some more testing oh my God what
it uh NOP yeah I'm not digging the flickering
light uh no girl go get your flashlight oh no
what it's like freezing in there oh yeah wow
breath is showing it's like this girl's got
to be like frozen over what's Burke got to
do when I went to get the thorine I had him
stay with her and haven't heard huh what
Brook's dead oh no what he fell down from
the top of the steps right outside by
the time he hit M Street he broke his
neck oh my God oh no oh no uh-uh I would
I would pick her up and drag her straight
to church and say listen even if I'm
not a Believer take her oh my God are
you comfortable Reagan yes how old are
you she's an incredible actress mhm is
there someone inside you sometimes if he
talks to me I think he'll leave you do you
want him to leave you yes oh my God this
poor girl is traumatized if you are there
you two are hypnotized and must answer all my
questions let's say this in a hypnotist who are
you
whoa oh my goodness that's a crazy shot oh William
F Kinder homicide perk Denning good father was
found at the bottom of those steps leading
to m street with his head turned completely
around yeah yeah okay you're the psychiatrist
you know who was sick at the time who wasn't I
don't know anyone who fits that description but
a psychiatrist was put in jail for not telling
the police what he knew about a patient thing I
could always tell the judge it was a matter of
confession H he's good it looks like the type of
disorder that's rarely ever seen anymore except
in primitive color we call it oh man with those
scratches now you ever heard of exorcism it uh
has worked the victim's belief in possession
belief in the power of exorcism can make it
disappear at this point I'd be willing to
try anything oh yeah also where are the
psychiatrists when they said uh Burke had passed
away for some reason I thought they were talking
about that guy that yeah I didn't realize
they were talking about the director from
her mood the guy who was drunk at the party
right I guess I think his name she wouldn't
be I don't think she would be dating him right
the helper cuz when the daughter asked earlier
but oh my God I would padlock her door just
to be like don't come after me in the night
sweetheart
oh my God is it that Stone from the
beginning yeah did you put it there
of course I didn't I didn't put it
excuse me mam what she really brings
a lot of intensity to this role mhm she's all
wound up it isn't likely he would fall from
a window at the deceased was killed and
then pushed from your daughter's window
H oh those look similar to the at the beginning
uh I'll come back when she's feeling better I'm
actually sure the mom would like that because
that means she got better so it's like fine
right that's a lot of new crazy
information on top of what already is going
on
you oh my God Jesus no no no no
oh duh
what oh boy oh my
God you
did okay let's get this guy to help please oh
my God need an exorcism oh my God it just so
happens that somebody very close to is is
probably possessed and needs an exorcist
it's my little girl you could do it yourself no I
couldn't I need Church approval and that's rarely
given I would say just come see her yeah there
we go you know he felt powerless to help his
mother maybe this could be a good yeah way for
him to yeah like an arc for him kind of thing
oh my God hello Reagan what oh my God the makeup
is amazing though what I'm Damien Caris and I'm
the devil where's Reagan in here with us wow
show me a Reagan and I'll loosen one of the
straps when you're helping all Al the boy
father your mother's in here with his cat
oh oh that is that is low that is so low then
you must know my mother's maiden name what is
it no
jeez why does the Slime have to match your
eyes so precisely I can't that f it would
scare the crap out of me so much wonder
if he's willing to perform an exorcism now
well he better be look I'm only against the
possibility of doing your daughter more harm
than good nothing you could do could make it
any worse seriously yeah it's already really
bad buddy you ask me what I think is best for
your daughter 6 months under observation in
the best hospital you can find did you know
my mother died recently yes I did I'm very
sorry no is Reagan aware of it not at all why'
you ask cuz she knew also like schizophrenics
don't change their voice that much I was going
to say her this girl is like like yeah she's
a little girl and her voice is like extra
deep yeah also her eyes changed to bright
green yeah the vomit was bright green look
like fresh avocados I mean it's all sorts
of complicated I mean I I hope you can hear
me can you hear me okay well uh let me see
it's a cool shot yeah how it's I was I was
noticing that too as you said it what an
excellent day for exorcism you'd like that
intensely but wouldn't that drive you out
of Reagan the makeup is insane yeah I'm curious
what happens when you do that like does it just
come out or does it go back down how long
are you planning to stay in Ran until she
rots and lies stinking in the Earth what's
that holy water holy water it burns who are
you what
the nering I don't think I'd ever be
able to sleep again if I experienced
that no way no way want a drink please can
I have like 10 drinks I told Reagan that
was holy water I sprinkled it on her and
she reacted very violently It's tap water
and that doesn't help support a case for
possession I'm like also didn't he see her
head turn all the way around that I'm like
and you don't think she he's like come on
now ah what is
that oh is that like
writing oh it says help me oh it's from Reagan
inside got it oh poor thing oh that music it's
terrible you would want to do the exorcism
yourself yes I doubt there's any danger in
just having him assist what about the Exorcist
have you any ideas maybe the guy from the
beginning about Lancaster marin oh ocean he was
over in Iraq I think I read that he was working
on a bingo you got it he's had experience
I didn't know that the exorcism supposedly
lasted months heard it damn near killed him what
did they say at the beginning evil against evil
yeah feel like I've seen this image somewhere
yeah it's spooky him getting out of the cab
been come in out like I know I've seen this
image somewhere yeah okay this right that
looks like a poster right yeah I've seen this
before it's cool shot yeah is Father Carris
here yes Father father Caris I was wondering
when we were going to get packed from the
beginning oh God the demon is a liar he will
like to confuse us the attack is psychological
Damian so don't listen remember that oh
goodness so far I'd say there seemed to
be three she's convinced that there's only
one he's experienced in this wow really
hope the makeup team won in Academy Award
or something cuz this is amazing they did
yeah our father in Heaven oh God let the
enemy have no power over I'm the son of
iniquity be to harm your mother's and Hell
faithless holy Lord Almighty father the bed
to crush that roaring lion hasten to our
call for help God forever and ever amen oh
Lord hear my prayer what the oh my God
and let my cry come unto thee Almighty
lord gave to your Holy Apostles the power
to [__] underfoot serpents and scorpions
whoa oh my God no no I can't oh my
God okay just pretend like it's gak oh god
father
my goodness this is incredible
concentration oh my God this is
like so much you out unclean Spirit show up
your ass in the name of Jesus Christ who in
the name of the father and of the son by
this sign of the Holy Cross of our Lord
Jesus Christ with the father and the
Holy Spirit no it's coming all the way
around you K shut up you sh command you by
the judge of the oh no this is It's the power
holy dude the effects are amazing in this
yeah the power of Christ compels you the
power of Christ compels you the power of
Christ compels you God the Father commands
you the blood of the martys commands
you oh no oh
no what let's rest before we start
wow really struck in but the mother comment
bro I would get out of that room right
now oh his pills oh right from the beginning
yeah he's like I need to take the
whole damn lot I mean he's this is a
lot that's messed
up de you do this to me oh no her
heart she going to Coma you're not
my mother don't listen why me Our Father
who out in heaven hellow be thy name is it
over is she going to die
no is it her father calling
or the detective yeah the
detective oh goodness gracious oh no what
happened what and what is she doing under
the corner of the bed no ah no oh no
you better grab that holy water real
quickness ah damn you got to step
your game up now you son of a
[__]
take me this dude's a boxer too take me
me what
what oh my goodness this is how they all die
oh oh I did not see that coming at
all oh my God I feel like it's
still in the room cuz it went
in him and then he looked normal
and he jumped out the window oh
god oh boy I really was not expecting that at
all mean either do you want to make a confession
oh he's still alive oh he's oh are you sorry
for having a God all the s of your past
life I think he's still
possessed yeah let's get out of town yeah I'd
be like we're going to leave and never come
back ever not even to visit I found this
in your room is it the necklace yeah she
doesn't remember any of it that's good
honey this is Father Dy hi Father hello
does he possess it now what feel like it's
in she just recognized the neck thing and
knowing that the priest helped her when she
was possessed and that's why she yeah I feel
like he possesses it now uh oh because he was
blessing the other guy when he was dying yeah
I thought you'd like to keep this yeah yeah
you're going to need it why don't you keep
it we going to get the the music the
iconic music from the had your lunch
no hope that house gets condemned torn down yeah
oh boy oh all right okay yeah I mean all right
that's gonna H hunt you for a good time yeah I
mean it's just the green the green gak is g to
stick with me yeah like defin oh Max vono Wonder
yeah okay um no I mean I I definitely get why
that's such an iconic horror film yeah um I don't
know I I'm going to have to have a talk with my
father I don't I mean again 1973 was a different
time period i they're saying stuff like that maybe
in the 70s they were like we don't say that you
know I know but the whole theater got cleared up
I mean again there were definitely moments that
were frightening for sure totally I mean I just
don't know if I was the language yeah I just
don't know if I buy the whole them going have
to call my dad out on that we'll have a talk with
him about that but uh talking about the whole I
really I mean it was definitely a slow burn but
you know the way it was paced and you know the
type of film making they were going for I actually
appreciated uh the way it was done and I thought
that it was I love the way that they got us so
invested in Reagan and her mother so early on in
the film so that when The Possession did happen
like you really cared for this character and you
wanted you know the the exorcism to happen so that
she was going to be okay uh rather than her being
an annoying character that you didn't care for um
also too the makeup in this movie and the special
effects for 1973 fantastically done uh there was a
sense of eeriness uh at all times like even when a
a phone call would would happen or just like you
know sounds of of like a h whatever it was like
I was always on the edge of my seat I felt like
uh there was a lot of suspense and tension which
I feel like a lot of good horror films do a good
job of doing um so from perspective I appreciated
the film um and a lot of religious uh overtones
of course um you know about possession and then
just uh and such and but what did you think of the
film I mean they did a really good job of setting
the foundation with all of the characters even at
the end with the with the guy that we saw at the
very top of the film going through the artifacts
and he's freaking out with his pills and then at
the end he's in the bathroom with his pills and we
don't even really know what they are but we do KN
know that it's like linked to that evil I mean
the guy's just like well versed in evil I like
the small things that they they set up it's not
like they had to do any uh um oh God what do you
what's the word for it uh they didn't do a lot of
uh Exposition I kept wanting to say exorcism they
didn't do a lot of exposition in regards to like
having to explain certain things like meaning oh
sure they mentioned he wrote a book let him come
do the Exorcist blah blah blah blah blah a lot of
it was mainly just like where we are right here
right now with mom and daughter and how badly
it started to obviously affect the family along
with obvious the sound design was insane I mean
we never even found out like why is that noise oh
it was just like the demon in the house the whole
time even before the daughter was like possessed
hearing those sounds up in the atct there's so
many things that were just set that were scary
and weird and like horror mov esque um and then
once we get off with like uh the the daughter and
getting into uh healing her through the exorcism
I mean that was like we have we have all been
waiting it kind of was like okay finally now I and
I was very curious to see what would happen I did
not expect the switch at the end I just thought
they were going to be keep yelling I the Christ
the body of Christ compels you and that it would
eventually go away I yeah I agree with you I I did
not see that all coming as well I just thought it
was going to get out of her body and that would be
it um I thought the acting was fantastic too from
everyone from the mother uh to the pre uh I mean
I thought the the the priest too um the one who um
uh at the we saw at the beginning in Iraq and then
of course he was the main priest in performing uh
the exorcism and uh the PRI the priest that we I
can't remember his name in the film but the priest
that we were focusing on mainly throughout the
fil PR the boxer priest with his mother uh who
unfortunately passed away in the film and he felt
guilty about that not being there by her side um
and you know I I I felt that guilt I felt bad
for him and just like you know that that sense
of you know where he was coming from and like you
know that he wanted to really help this this poor
girl and what she was going through and that he
was able to you know he felt so helpless in that
moment with his mother and that he wanted to do
something for this uh Poor Unfortunate uh girl
uh in terms of what was happening to her and I
I really thought he had a nice Arc um you know
especially at the end where I again I did not
see that coming but I also I love the I kind of
used this word earlier but I love the intensity
that all the actors brought to their roles um
especially the mother the priest but that little
girl too the daughter that is not an easy role I
think she's messed up right she had to be messed
up from this role because yeah that's a tough one
I mean to do uh I mean because at the begin I mean
just in the the cutesy scenes that she was doing
at the beginning she did a great job there but
like the makeup and then having to pretend like
your POS it was that's a really difficult I mean
any acting is hard in general but for however old
she was in real life that is a very tough and
challenging Ro young yeah and she did a heck
of a job she did a fantastic job I also wonder if
it messed her up like a little bit cuz the stuff
that she has to go through and say and and act out
and she did a really really great job uh she did a
good job playing demented just wondering if you
were a little demented after too I'd be curious
to know yeah and also too I as I also mentioned
during the reaction that music which I had heard
from haunted houses and just I also I listen to
Pandora I know I'm a nerd I listen to movie music
Danny Elfman radio it's really good listen to it
uh I love that iconic music oh yeah it's so damn
good and you pointed out too the sound design
this movie it's really really good I mean again
it just got me on the edge of my seat just from
telephones ring and everything like everything
is scaring the crap out of me right now so yeah
and it was it is more just more uh Cinema forward
type of a horror movie where all of the shots that
they're choosing whether it be like a crane shot
from above bringing us in or even static to like
a dolly shot tracking people as as they speak they
did take a lot of they took a lot of air lot of
space in scenes that didn't really necessarily
yeah it's a setup but they don't like really
matter like when she's around with all of the
doctors they took a lot of time just just taking
the reaction of the doctor after the mom freaked
out following him all the way around until he's
like now it's the reveal of like I think have
you heard of what an exorcism is um I just didn't
I enjoyed that they took their time with it just
with shots like that you wouldn't get that today
or you would but I think up Abes would be like
it's too long uh or take it out or something and I
really felt for the mother too I can only imagine
like you're going everywhere psychiatrists doctors
it's like you feel so hopeless in this like what
the hell is this and what the hell do I do you
know type of thing um so even like the CAT scan
and her her getting like all of her x-ray I mean
even that was like terrifying to watch oh that's
going to stick with me to the the in the neck the
needle in the neck yeah blood started coming out
no thank you and I was on your side where I'm
like I about put you under please yeah like put
her under I do not mind like a bat going against
a head and it's sweet sweet revenge and you see
blood that the neck no thank you uh also just
like the green projectile vomit no thanks um
I'm kind of curious what they did use for that um
avocados I swear to God it literally it looks like
it looks like fresh green avocados mixed with
like green food coloring and like mayonnaise
and no I they didn't use that cuz she can't keep
that in her mouth but I'm like ah you know what
shot freaked me out the most throughout uh when
she was possessed by the devil the whatever when
she was going down the stairs like oh God yeah
the blood just came out MTH the blood squ out
of the mouth that shot freaked me out the most of
anything that was probably the most iconic shot
to me and freaked out shot as well I think that
one mixed with her head just it's coming around
we can see it coming no thank you that's uh yeah
I think those two really like set me off I mean
in general this film is a great is a great horror
film super like Cinema esque uh I really love the
shots obviously they they they did focus a lot on
like the cinematography which I very much enjoy
which you should in a horror movie but there's
some that they don't really maybe it's more script
forward this one the shots that they chose even
the fog they put in front of the house when the
E when the uh the priest comes to visit it like
we said that looks like the poster they always
had that fog going in front of the house setting a
a tone even later in the middle of the movie when
we see the neighborhood for a moment it went to
Blue tone like after she became possessed I think
there was just like little things like that that
they put uh you know effort and thought into uh
that I think made it just a really Great Piece of
Cinema oh yeah no it's like I said I I obviously
I've never seen the film but that shot I I know
I've seen that whether it was from the poster just
from a tri something but it was it's just again
iconic that that image it's definitely that image
because I do I've never seen this before and the
image of the girl with the green eyes I've never
seen that before with her skin all weird uh and
that to me would be like yeah let's put that on
the poster it looks the most messed up I got to
imagine they at minimum were nominated for uh I
I don't know if in 1973 or 1974 whatever this uh
the nominations could have been for this film I
got to imagine that they were at least nominated
for best uh special effects and makeup and like
the breath stuff in the cold room and I was like
wait did we have those effects back in the 70s is
just what my brain kept thinking I was really
impressed yeah yeah because now you don't even
have to second guess it but I'm like obviously
they're not making them work in an environment
that's like very very cold to where their breast
shows it's all after you know special effect stuff
course um and I just kept thinking did we have
that in the 70s when they made this movie because
it all looks fantastic uh in the bed move I wonder
how they did that um because it's not like they
would be green screening it out with someone
like lifting the bed I'm sure they just put it
on Hydraulics and you just you it's clear stuff
but uh I don't think we're like rotoscoping out
in the 70s so all of it nice job for the 70s
I don't know what all the special effects we
had back then but great job no but again really
good uh great what would you I'd probably go in
the 8.5 8.8 just going to ask somewhere in that
range yeah I I'll go I'll go uh I'll go wait I'll
go wait man um great film loved it I feel like
now when I see people walking around I am a huge
fan of Halloween and spooky time so now when I
see people walking around with an exorcist shirt
I can be like I get it I get it I'm with you I
understand it freaky any last thoughts you can
say the power of Christ compels you oh yeah good
good good maybe I'll just wear that shirt people
will be like Exorcist right they'll they'll get
it it'll be like an inside thing um that's it
that's all I got I mean this movie kind of messed
me up it kind of made me tired cuz my adrenaline
was so high cuz I was scared and normally when I
watch scary movies on this channel I'm like tired
after I'm like I don't have all the thoughts right
I'm not being as eloquent and um yeah I don't have
as many words I think my father hyped this up a
little too much just just a little I was freed in
terms of in terms of the scariness fact it was a
great film I just mean the scariness Factor hype
up but yeah I really enjoyed it though it's a good
film he's got to go home and call his dad and yell
at him and I have to go take a nap so we love you
guys so much uh don't forget you know like comment
leave us nice things tell us what we should watch
next we love you all and we'll see you later
goodbye